many of us
spend a large part of our lives in one
way or another
feeling stuck that is in a state where a
strong desire to move forward on an
issue
meets with an equally strong compulsion
to stay fixed
where one is for example we might at one
level
powerfully want to leave a job in
finance in order to retrain in
architecture
but at the same time remain blocked by a
range of doubts
hesitations counter arguments and guilty
feelings
or we might be impelled to leave our
marriage while simultaneously
unable to imagine any realistic life
outside of it
to act feels horrific but doing nothing
is killing us as well every avenue
appears shut off
and so one ruminates turns over the
question late at night
tries the patience of therapists and
watches life go by
with mounting anxiety and self-disgust
as an outsider one might be tempted to
ask questions
to move things on why don't you try to
enroll in a course
to see if you might like a new area of
work why don't you discuss your
dissatisfactions with your partner
why don't you go to counselling what
about splitting up
but we're likely to find that our friend
can't make any progress
whatever we say it seems as if they are
subject to a kind of law
disbarring them from progressing not the
sort of law you'd find in the statutes
of the country they live in
but some sort of personal law a law that
might go like this
make sure you don't achieve satisfaction
in your career
make sure your relationship has no life
in it
but cannot be abandoned make sure you
aren't happy in the place you live in
in order to understand the origins of
these laws we have to look backwards
difficult childhoods and the complicated
families they unfold in
might be the originators of a lot of
these restrictive
unspoken laws whose impact echoes
across our lives some of these laws
might go like this
make sure you never shine it would upset
your little sister
or you have to be cheerful not to let my
depression break through
or never be creatively fulfilled because
it would remind me of my
envy or reassure us that we are clever
by winning all the prizes at school
or we need you to achieve to make us
feel okay about ourselves
or you would disappoint me if you became
boisterous and
one day sexual of course no one ever
directly says such things in a family
laws couldn't operate if they could so
easily be seen
but the laws are there nevertheless
holding us into
a particular position as we grow up and
then
once we've left home continuing to
surreptitiously distort our
personalities
away from the path of their legitimate
growth
it can be hard to draw any connection
between adult
stuck situations and any childhood laws
we may miss the link between our
reluctance to act at work
and a situation with dad at home 30
years before
but we can hazard a principle
nevertheless
any long-term stuckness is likely to be
the result of
butting in to some sort of law inherited
unknowingly
from childhood we are stuck because we
are being overly loyal to an idea of
something being
impossible generated in the distant past
impossible because it was threatening to
someone we cared for
or depended on a long time ago
therefore one of the main paths to
liberation
lies in coming to see that the law
exists
and then unpicking its warped and
unnecessary logic
we can start by asking whether beneath
our practical dilemma
there may be a childhood law at work
encouraging us to stay
where we are we can dig beneath the
surface problem
in search of the emotional structure
that might be being engaged
so for example in the unconscious
architecture
equals the creativity dad never enjoyed
or
sexual fulfillment equals what hurt my
lovable mum
we may discover that some of the reason
we can't give up on finance and
take up a more imaginative role is
because throughout childhood
we had to accept a law that we couldn't
be both creatively fulfilled
and make money in order to protect our
volatile father
from his own envy and inadequacy or we
can't leave our marriage because
unconsciously we're coming up against a
law from childhood
that tells us that being a good boy
means renouncing
once more bodily and visceral sides
the specifics will differ but the
principle of a hidden law from childhood
can explain a huge number of adult
stucknesses
the way forward is first and foremost
hence to realize
that there might be a law in operation
when we get stuck
though we aren't merely being cowardly
or slow in not progressing
and that we feel trapped because we are
in our faulty minds
back in a cage formed in childhood
which we have to be able to see think
about and then
patiently dismantle we can along the way
accept that we are now adults which
means that the original family drama
no longer has to apply we don't have to
worry about upsetting parental figures
their taboos were set up to protect them
but they're making us ill we can feel
sad for the laws that these damaged
figures from the past
imposed on us often with no active
malevolence
but we can recognize that our imperative
is to move
them aside and act with the emotional
freedom that's always been our
birthright
we may need to be disloyal to a way of
being
that protected someone we cared about or
depended on
in order to start to be loyal to a more
important person still
ourselves
our decision dice are a tool to help you
make wiser decisions in work
love and the rest of your life
you